[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an indian psychological
drama film called tereza mean par
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
ishan is an eight-year-old imaginative
kid widely known as a troublemaker among
his mates he fails every subject and is
the lowest ranking student in his
classroom he is in his second year of
third grade and by the looks of his
report card he will have to repeat the
same grade again in contrast to ishan
his elder brother johann is an ideal
student outside studies he plays tennis
and is competing in the upcoming
interstate tennis championship ishan
frequently gets into fights with the
neighborhood kids who bully him one day
a kid's mother complains about ishan's
behavior to his father nand kishore he
has to embarrassingly apologize to the
kid and his mother after they leave he
shoves ishan to the floor to discipline
him although non-kashore loves his
children he is too harsh on ishan he
believes that ishan's low scores and
inability to do basic tasks are because
of his laziness the next day at school
ishan's english teacher asks him to read
a line from a book he tries his best but
can hardly form a word he has difficulty
in understanding the letters but the
teachers mistake it for him being a brat
when she repeatedly urges him to read he
yells gibberish
and is sent out of the class it is not a
new thing for ishan to be punished in
fact he spends most of his time outside
rather than studying because the
teachers think of him as a disturbance
to the other students that day ishon
hadn't done his math homework to avoid
facing the math teacher he runs away
from school and spends the entire day
wandering around the neighborhood he
enjoys the day to his fullest buying ice
cream spending time by the sea and
analyzing the passersby by the end of
the day he returns to his school bus
without anyone noticing his absence at
home we see him make a beautiful
painting ishaan loves to paint and his
imaginative mind helps the cause
resulting in over-the-top pieces later
his mother maya tries to tutor him and
make him do his homework she notices
that his handwriting is awful and he can
hardly spell anything right she
associates his inability with laziness
and scolds him like everyone else the
next day ishon will have to provide his
teacher with an absent note from his
parents scared of getting in trouble he
begs his brother to write the note for
him johan makes him promise he will
never skip school again and writes the
note the kid shows it to his teacher who
doesn't question its authenticity he
also pretends to cough to make it seem
like he was actually sick that day the
math teacher surprises the kids with a
test ishan has handed the test paper but
to him the letters look like they're
dancing the first question asks him the
multiplication of three with nine in his
head the kid imagines the third planet
earth and the ninth planet pluto
fighting each other he fantasizes about
the earth destroying pluto and
rationalizes that the answer is three
leaving the rest of the questions blank
he submits the test when asked by his
friends he confidently claims that he
enjoyed the test thoroughly the next day
nand cashore returns from a business
trip ishan is overjoyed by his father's
return and hugs him dearly however
during breakfast nand cashore finds the
fake absent note from the day before
upon investigating he finds out about
ishan running away from school and
wandering alone in the streets the very
next day the parents go to meet his
teachers and the principal who condemn
his behavior in class they also find out
about the recent math test and its
results the principal assumes ishan is a
special child who needs to be sent to
school for children with disabilities
nand kishore is horrified at the thought
of his son being disabled both parents
are worried about their kid's future so
they decide to send him to a boarding
school ishan is completely against the
idea he rebels and cries begging them to
keep him home and although the parents
do not want to be separated from him
either they do what they think will be
best for him that night ishan dreams of
losing his mother in a crowd and wakes
up screaming when she tries to calm him
down he promises to study harder if they
let him stay home this breaks maya's
heart but nan kishore is adamant about
his decision the day finally comes when
ishaan is taken to the boarding school
in the countryside he will have to share
a dorm with other children and will only
be allowed to meet his family once a
month it is a nightmare for the
eight-year-old who has never been away
from his home the hostile warden
welcomes him by declaring that his old
ways won't be tolerated here after
touring the school the family leaves
with a heavy heart ishan just watches
their car drive away with teary eyes he
stays like that for several minutes even
after the car vanishes from his view
when it starts to get dark he walks
inside the hostel while still crying he
doesn't talk to anyone and hardly eats
dinner at night when he cannot sleep he
goes to the bathroom and cries quietly
missing his mother meanwhile maya
reaches home and goes through ishan's
belongings to her dismay she finds a
flip book of him being taken away from
his family the book breaks her heart and
she realizes how much the kid dreads
being away from them in the hostel ishan
struggles to do normal things like tying
his tie and shoelaces that's okay ishan
i still struggle with those things too
on his first day the hindi teacher mr
tiwari makes him sit on the first bench
with the class topper rajan the teachers
soon realize that ishan isn't normal he
hardly pays attention in class and is
physically punished by his art teacher
nothing changes from how he was in the
previous school he is always sent
outside the class as punishment and is
excluded from the class activities for
ruining them with time he gets so
frustrated that he tears his books apart
and throws them into the bin he stops
trying to do better in school and goes
into a spiral of depression and
self-loathing when his parents come to
meet him after a month he locks himself
inside a room and bursts out crying for
the first time since he last saw them on
being urged he runs outside and takes
several laps of the basketball court to
rebel the family takes him to a hotel
for the night to give him a break from
his life at the hostel johan gives him a
hamper of painting supplies as a gift
but little does he know ishan has cut
out his creative side and stopped
painting altogether the next day the
family bids him farewell and leaves him
alone yet again later that day ishan is
the lowest he has ever been he looks
down from the terrace of the school
thinking about how it would feel to jump
from that height his only friend rajon
interrupts his thoughts and tells him
about their new art teacher ishan
doesn't think much of it because no
teacher has ever helped him however it
is surprising to the kids that the new
teacher ram enters the class in a joker
costume he sings a song plays a flute
makes them dance and lets them enjoy the
class in contrast to all the other
teachers while the oldie sean would have
loved this the depressed one doesn't
participate in any of it as their first
task the students are asked to draw or
paint anything they want ram wants them
to show their creative side so he knows
what he has to work on next the children
start to draw several things all
different from one another but ishan
doesn't even touch the paper initially
ram assumes that the kid is taking some
time to think but even when the class
ends ishan's paper is still blank
worried ram asks him what is wrong but
doesn't get a reply
that evening maya calls to talk to ishan
but he only holds the phone to his ears
and doesn't say anything he is informed
that they will have to postpone the next
visit by a week because of johan's
tennis competition to ishan this only
confirms that his family doesn't care
about him he sheds a single tear and
walks away without saying anything the
next day ram sees ishan kneeling down
outside the classroom intrigued by his
behavior he asks rajan about him rajan
reveals that ishan has difficulty
understanding letters no matter how hard
he tries ram teaches in a school for
disabled children so he has an eye out
for kids who are special to find out
more about ishan he goes through his old
notebooks and finds a pattern of similar
mistakes even while teaching the special
children he cannot get the thought of
ishan out of his head he used to have
the same problem in his childhood so he
feels sympathetic to the kid weeks later
he recognizes what ishan's actual
problem is and travels to his hometown
to meet his parents they welcome him and
let him take a look at ishaan's bedroom
ram is surprised to find out that he
sean used to paint this makes him even
sadder that the kid lost his sparkle
because of the pressure that was put on
him nand kishore belittles his son
claiming that he is lazy and he hates
studying ram retaliates and shows him
the pattern in ishan's mistakes he often
inverts the letters as if he has
difficulty differentiating between them
still the father associates it with
laziness but ram bluntly claims that he
is wrong he declares ishan has a
neurological condition called dyslexia
that causes him to not understand
certain patterns like letters and words
in addition he has difficulty
coordinating which causes him to not be
able to tie his shoes the kid must have
been suffering so much because no one
understood that he couldn't read and
assumed he was just being lazy so in
other words it's the parents who are
being lazy oh snap nand kashore thinks
ram is calling his son a [ __ ] and
lashes out at him to make him understand
ram asks him to read foreign letters
written on a box when non-kashore is
scolded for not understanding the
letters he finally realizes what his kid
must be going through still he refuses
to acknowledge that his son can make a
living out of his only passion painting
ram is determined to prove him wrong
when he returns to school the next day
he teaches the kids about all the famous
historical figures who weren't so good
at studying when they were children he
gives them examples of scientists actors
and philosophers which makes ishan feel
a lot better about himself when ram asks
them who invented the light bulb ishan
speaks for the first time in weeks and
answers thomas edison ram sees a shimmer
of hope for the boy to learn later that
day ishan is by the pond when he uses
rubber bands and leaves to make a
working boat ram is so impressed that he
brings the structure home and keeps it
as a decoration ishan's creative senses
start to flow again but he still has a
long way to go before learning to study
like the other kids his age one day ram
goes to the school's principal and tells
him about ishan's problem the principle
suggests they send him to the school for
children with special needs but ram is
confident that ishan can study with the
regular kids he suggests the teachers
understand the kid's problem and help
him accordingly when the principal says
it is not possible ram offers to teach
ishan every day after school the
principal allows it for the sake of the
child starting the next day ram uses
various innovative methods to help issan
differentiate letters of the alphabet
they learn using sandboxes plato sensory
methods and so on ishan also takes help
from audiobooks and stairs to learn to
calculate in only two months he begins
to understand the letters that other
teachers couldn't teach him in several
years one day nand kishore comes to the
school to talk to ram and boast about
how they are researching more about
their son's condition he wants ram to
know that he's not an absent father and
is proud to be the way he is ram on the
other hand blames the father for being
the reason the kid lost self-confidence
which even non-casual cannot deny on his
way out he sees ishan trying to read
from the notice board regretful of
unknowingly hurting his child he tears
up and cannot get himself to face him a
few days later ram organizes a painting
competition for both teachers and the
students of the school everyone gathers
in the amphitheater and participates
ishan uses the painting supplies that he
was gifted by his brother for the first
time the competition starts and everyone
gets busy drawing even the teachers
enjoy the event and do their best by the
end of it ishan creates a beautiful
painting of himself sitting by the pond
he goes to the front to submit the
painting and sees that ram has painted a
portrait of him he is left speechless at
the site a while later it is announced
that the winning painting will be on the
front of the new edition of their
yearbook the principal proclaims that
the decision was difficult because two
paintings stood out the most rams and
ishan's in the end ishan is declared the
winner while the second prize goes to
ram the crowd erupts and cheers for the
first time in his life ishon feels
recognized for his talent he cannot help
but cry and runs to his teacher to hug
him in the last scene maya and nan
kishore come to the school for the end
of the year parent-teacher meeting the
principal boasts about ishan's talent
showing them his painting on the front
of the school's yearbook unused to the
new attention the parents are left
shocked the principal also praises ram
for doing a great job teaching the kid
in the way he needed it later the
parents meet ishan's teachers who show
them the report card and compliment the
kids undeniable progress outside the
couple watches their son playing and cry
tears of happiness nantkishore thanks
ram for helping ishan and apologizes for
his behavior lastly ishan bids farewell
to ram and goes back to his hometown for
a vacation
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching